I do things that might not be safe to do
like with cars and toys and you know
things that aren't meant to be for when
you're driving can you give us an
example like an a legal example
[Music]
so Bitcoin millionaire and crypto
founder John Forsyth who is a prominent
figure in the crypto space has been
found dead with a gunshot wound oh my
God are they saying it's a foul play oh
yeah so um he was missing for a week
after failing to show up at work he used
to work at this place called Mercy
Hospital in Cassville Missouri why would
you work so hard if you're a Bitcoin
millionaire it's pretty weird right I
ask myself that same question what's
that Nick you said what does he do at
the hospital
um he was well it didn't take what he
does for the hospital it says that he
was the co-founder of a coin
um and this is where he was found but he
was missing after filling the show for
work at the Mercy Hospital in Cassville
Missouri his unlocked car was discovered
near the hospital with his belongings a
wallet path pass passport laptop work
briefcase oh so it wasn't a robbery the
police say that they don't suspect Foul
Play in his death so they think it's
self-inflicted why no suicide no let's
let's go through it right so he was the
co-founder of
onfo coin a I think it's on full I guess
never heard of it a referral based
cryptocurrency I hadn't either a
referral based crypto Project based on
social mining he was also an early
adopter of Bitcoin and a vocal critic of
the US dollar yes
in 2020 Forbes called him a Bitcoin
millionaire with the passion for
mathematics uh and Bitcoin technology
emerged his death is the latest in a
series uh that we've been tracking
mysterious fatalities among crypto
enthusiasts right and entrepreneurs
you've heard of this right yep the
crypto Billy knows I keep killing them
in April got named Bob Lee he's the
creator of cash app former technology
Chief at Square he got stabbed to death
in San Fran oh yeah last June mircia
popesco I think I butchered it
controversial Bitcoin billionaire
drowned in Costa Rica we talked about
that that was like off the boat right
yep yep
um some speculate that their crypto
fortunes are maybe involved that's kind
of crazy who would have thought but some
also say hey their their fortunes might
be lost forever because they're they're
crypto their private keys are lost which
is better for other people sure it's
good for the supply
scary little is known right this just
happened today or this was just reported
today wow what do you what's your take
on all the all the Bitcoin billions I
keep disappearing yeah yeah scary as
[__] it's just crazy yeah but I don't I
don't want to be a Bitcoin billionaire
do you ever think about [__] like that
because like
I'm just always like man if they try to
[__] kidnap me what should I do
well good thing I don't have any money
for them to take but there are people
that think I have a lot of money so
there's probably a Target on my back
um but one day when I make it on crypto
you know like these guys when we come
back dude I'm like I might hire a
private Army but what if they turn on me
they will yeah
how do you know they will they will they
probably I mean I think it's it's even
though you look like you have a lot of
money I think if someone's smart enough
to assassinate you they're smart enough
to fact check your funds and then they
go he ain't got no money it's probably
already happened
or it's like maybe we should all just
pitch in on a massive compound and arm
each other and we become our bodyguard
Army but we're all billionaires like Bin
Laden so smart oh is that what he did
yeah it did he [__] he had his one
compounds built in Pakistan or we could
maybe we could hire a security guard but
since we're poor we could all chip in
for that one Navy SEAL yeah he's like a
real good one to protect by 20. I mean
he's retired he's like 79 years old
[Laughter]
okay okay discount mind okay let's go
baby all right we're gonna I do want the
deals yeah all right we're gonna buy
real estate next to the White House
there guaranteed they got security for
like five miles squared radius yeah it's
really good with anti-missile all this
[__] right crazy so all we do we buy an
apartment next to the next to the
[__] white house right yeah and we
just live there
it's called coaster yeah we buy the
apartment next to the White House but we
paint the apartment like it's an
extension of the white house so the
security thinks it's all one because
Secret Service is so [__] dumb like
when do we add this new Wing I think
that's part of the White House right
there is that the west west
there's no way man you know how many
people died during the Insurrection
that's fatal I think a million people
died during the year well that's when
that's when we wear a trump hat when
they come by and then like then when
there's a pride parade we put on the
Biden hat we're gonna wear it we gotta
wear animal hides yeah yeah but what
about that movie Olympus Has Fallen when
they stormed the White House Oh I
thought that was the aliens or yeah
Independence Day where hovers right
above okay yeah dude how about this how
about we just live in Pagoda like in the
Bruce Lee movie and each level the
network gets higher and then it's Kareem
Abdul-Jabbar
but what if you leave your keys upstairs
and you go downstairs and you have to go
back up and get it because they didn't
have elevators
that's the problem it was great until
the cream thing sorry because then we're
gonna buy him in he's so rich yeah he's
so expensive yeah
[Laughter]
I don't know but then if you have a
helicopter you could land from top but
it's made out of paper though the house
is made out of paper okay okay but dude
I can't keep playing helicopters after
Kobe I won't do it yeah yeah I never
rode a helicopter yet
no really you guys after Kobe dude well
none of you guys will ride one wow
I'm not on them forever sometimes I
wonder why am I so health conscious and
you know trying to live healthy and
fitness and all this when my lifestyle
is gonna short my life hardcore you
think you have a crazy lifestyle
um I do things that might not be safe to
do like with cars and toys and you know
things that aren't meant to be for when
you're driving can you give us an
example like an illegal illegal example
that you're trying to dodge
a specific illegal area
what is this recently within the past 25
years that's why I'm like that what's
the point yeah I might as well eat a
Twinkie right if I'm gonna go dive and
yeah tweets aren't that bad try to catch
a shark with my bare hands or something
that's what we were saying about
geographical location makes a difference
too remember we were talking about that
dude who like switches blood with his
son to live forever but yet he could
probably just he could probably just get
like Diet gun by gunshot by living in
Cali
the funny thing is I think that dude
went like on a motorcycle tour and
everyone was like that's hilarious
because the probability yeah it's higher
if you get into it yeah dumb yeah yeah
not smart
yeah but I I think about that and I'm
like
um what should I do to protect myself
and my family
and what's your and what and then did
you get on a tangent so you didn't quite
get there or do you have a plan I have a
plan but I just don't have the money for
it so when I'm a rich man yeah I have a
blue my bootleg is just old school gun
that's all I got you know but it won't
protect me from laser beams yeah aliens
you need a circle mirror for the laser
beams alien Circle mirror yes they
[__] blast you just from deflective
package
you gotta always have one on your
persons and have a Bible too in case
they shoot you yeah thick Bible the
Bible not NIV King James bro and a
necklace with their grandma on it so
they can stop the bullet oh that's
really smart I have to look at amulet
with your grandma's photo on it yeah or
in John Wick just have a coat dude oh
yeah bulletproof
yeah yeah
yeah like what if you get
yeah what if it's a windy day and it's
like and then the cult doesn't block you
and it just shoots you yeah yeah but oh
my God just I don't spitballing
thankfully John Wick has never taken
place during the Santa Ana Santa Ana
wins yeah El Nino or something
did you ever feel like you needed a
bodyguard and you felt unsafe
um all the time in Venice Beach dude all
the time
I actually cleaned it up a pretty good
go to Venice Beach yeah it's a little
nice to eat that do you see this one how
is it now how was Venice Beach now I
haven't been since it's actually pretty
I was there the other week it's actually
pretty they cleaned it up oh nice I
didn't really see any homeless
encampments in the main area you know
they took over the handball course and
they were just living in them oh yeah
that's all cleaned up because during
covet times like people's uh like ring
and Nest cameras you'll just see random
people just start throwing down yeah you
got to go a little further for that now
but they're not in the main area anymore
yeah is it closer to the
um the wheel or further further away by
the way yeah like Santa Monica doesn't
[__] around and as soon as it hits
Venice Beach you'll see home as far okay
yeah yeah but I used to go and ride my
bike there at night so I could see the
fun stuff that was happening I think
they all just got jobs because of Karen
bass so they're all gone
[Music]
what kind of jobs do you think they have
I don't know Nick
just don't want to play along with you
Nick ask the host that yeah don't ask me
that that's the whole Ryan was like I
hosted it yesterday I don't know they're
nurses Nick I don't know oh really
no they all work for wag what a crazy
yeah
you think Elon Musk actually lives in a
small tiny home no no if he does why
yeah wasn't it like the thing oh Elon
Musk crashes on his friend's coaches
like there was like a hot article about
that I don't buy it at all do you do
anybody no that people's office is
probably 10 000 square feet yeah he
probably just stays in his office all
day isn't he always working I
right right there's plenty of place to
sleep huh no definitely would you do
with SpaceX that's a [__] Flex yeah
that's dope I spoke there oh let me give
me a tour did you meet Elon yeah no
that's not that important what were you
speaking about what were you speaking
about were you speaking about ice cream
partly yes entrepreneurship really to
the to the what team there well I I
assume going there that everyone would
be in suits and ties and a lot older and
then I walked in and everyone that came
into listening Speak I was like oh you
guys all look like me cool
that's cool literally yeah it's like a
young like a youth club a lot of youth
culture in there they have a lot of
funny references like they have the t2
in the the data room that has a sky that
has a Skynet sign nice
[Music]